hi and welcome back to rapid fire
language learning
today we're going to explore the
question how to think directly in your
target language
when we speak a foreign language we want
to sound sophisticated as if
we were speaking our own native language
but sometimes we don't have the tools if
we don't speak that language still
fluently so my piece of advice is to
simplify
to the bone if you have to say something
like for example i want to go to japan
because i've never been to japan before
make sure that you just break down the
sentence into two smaller sentences
because
the smaller the sentence the more
manageable it is something along the
lines of for example
i want to go to japan i've never been
there then you can use conjunctions
to progressively connect these simple
pieces
of content and form longer sentences
remember simple does not mean simplistic
if you apply this especially to
languages that have a different syntax
and a different
sentence structure then things warm up
pretty quickly
thanks for watching over and out